друзі Сьогодні нарешті дуже важливі
новини Міністерства оборони на виконання
нашого закону про збільшення виплат
кільком категоріям військовослужбовців
видало відповідний наказ закон було
прийнято ще в червні щодня давили на
уряд щоби закон було виконано після
прийняття цього наказу з червня
враховуючи військовослужбовці таких
категорій як Курсанти строковики
поранені отримують збільшення виплат
поранені до 20 000 а не 700 грн як це
було до сьогодні дуже важливо що буде
збільшено виплати командирам на лінії
фронту саме розміновувачам на лінії
фронту до 100 000 а тим саперам які
працюють е на деокупованих територіях до
30 000 Ну і важливо що працюємо щоби
такі накази вийшли і по інструкторам
виплати ще раз наголошую мають бути
закриті за чотири місяці починаючи з
червня Ну і працюємо далі для того щоби
як найшвидше спростити отримання
військовослужбовцями убд